hier marie müller trocken freunde athos
auf ks tricks am start und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video sehen
wir heute czempik spielen aber nicht
alleine
wisst ihr was auch youtube denn wir
haben heute die einzige arbeiten die
beste begleitung die man haben kann auch
eine richtig gute runde pvp reinzuhauen
wisse schon was ist es ist
da hört ist die fahrt gegen magische
miesmuschel wäre das nicht gedacht wir
fragen sie die magische miesmuschel
nicht loslaufen
wir haben noch eine menge fragen für uns
okay
können wir bitte einfach das jetzt
professionell machen ja also deutschland
bitte loslaufen
wunderbar
ich dachte mir nämlich ganz ehrlich
menschliche youtube sind zu kompliziert
ich will mit ihnen aufnehmen da kommt so
nachts um drei ist mir zu spät ich bin
müde magische miesmuschel das den stoff
behalten
aus der kiste geholt habe okay dann sag
ich es halt wenn es ihr zu hohes bildes
tyler da die sache ist die miesmuschel
wir mögen uns nicht so wirklich
die hat man nämlich schon so viele
runden versaut ist könnt ihr euch ihr
könnt euch wirklich nicht vorstellen so
verdammt wieder runden wo ihr aber so
kurz davor war das ding zu gewinnen oder
gerade saugen das equipment gefunden
hatte
dann habe ich das teil gefragt was man
munkelt dass die tablets so einfach
gesagt hat nein du miststück schon okay
was sagst du hier zu fluten
da wunderbar immerhin immerhin der stein
alles klar
ach wissen sie das wichtigste hab ich
noch gar nicht gefragt was worauf
könnten der konzernchef von goair
miesmuschel sind akkus auf ps freaks am
start
was soll junge dieses teil alter save my
fucking live ok dürfe die kisten
die ist von gutmann und ich schwöre euch
ich habe nicht getötet ich kann ich
gleich mal die einstellung zeigen
ich habe wirklich nicht getötet ich hab
nix dran verändert die hat positive und
negative neutrale antworten drin da seht
ihr das positiv negativ neutral alle
antworten sind drin
aber momentan ist mir einfach wohl
gesonnen ganz ehrlich ist einfach ist
ein guter tag um hier sonne scheint
rampling module laufen und die
miesmuschel ist auf meiner seite
miesmuschel
da habe ich noch eine kiste luton junge
alte das ding ist nice erhält der
schwede
ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich glaube dass
ich in die muschel ist wir haben glaube
ich unsere probleme überwunden ist ja
ich glaube wir haben wirklich unsere
probleme überwunden und verstehen es
jetzt deutlich besser kennt ihr das hier
allerdings spieler da draußen
das ist sehr tricky das ist nie und
nimmer normal also have to make great
das muss man auf jeden fall als hart
einstufen falls irgendwann vom
primitiven sieht wer war ganz flott von
euch okay hier ist die kiste miesmuschel
was hältst du davon wenn ich noch eine
kiste luthe ich hab dir vertraut doch
besser walter ja okay wenn du meinst
meinetwegen machen muss halt so wenn du
so willst ich weiß gar nicht wie ich
denn früher mal gesprungen so die junge
alter richtig klaus und dann kommt so
ein modell das gerade eben ist wirklich
wirklich da kommt so ein ziel war es
einfach mehr oder weniger geschenkt ist
es muss schon was hältst du davon wenn
ich mich einfach spontan umbringe also
in minecraft also ich einfacher sagen
okay soll ich mich denn jetzt so schön
wisst ihr wenn ihr so am boden seit auf
frauen durch verlassen mit 20 versteht
meine frau mich verlassen
sie seien am boden wissen nicht mehr wie
es weitergehen soll im leben die vaults
beenden und der kommunismus und redet
perfekt wir haben eine neue kiste
mission was sagst du dazu halt die
fresse dadurch die kiste wird er auf
machen es tut mir leid was verkackt
leute
wir haben es uns offiziell verkackt
dieses kleine dieses kleiner halt die
fresse gerade eben hat es einfach
verkackt mit der muschel das war's - mal
gas geben
neue kiste neues glück darf ich dran
nur hier gibt er bereits eine antwort
oder löscht ich wunderbar ohne als stein
schwert sehr schön alt übrigens leute
wenn ihr bock habt noch eine neue folge
mit der miesmuschel zu sehr wenn ihr so
weit gefallen hat dann schreibt dass man
die kommentare dann kann ich mir das
überlegen dass ich sie vielleicht doch
nicht endgültig löschte mein handy nicht
in den müll schmeißen in den müll in die
müllpresse neue küste darauf machen oder
wie fühlst du dich
dankeschön dankeschön du musst stück
kalt ganz ehrlich alter schwede das war
klaus wenn ich fast wieder runtergeht
dittmann mein volk in leben so alles
klar
ok wack das modul stadt noch zu kisstel
ruhig da vorne ist das mal gas geben
wir schaffen es verschafft uns ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz okay wahrscheinlich
gefallen die wahrscheinlich ich bin ein
selbstständiges wesen muschel
ich brauche ich nicht mehr sagt zack
zack zack ok oh gott oh gott da kommt so
viel da kommt so viel ich werde
angegriffen muschel darf nicht werden
okay es war zwar keine sagt zu dem man
zustimmen kann aber ich sehe das einfach
mal ja und dann werden wir zumindest
zumindest mal gegen den ersten
wir müssen jetzt natürlich vor jedem
einzelnen kampf die erlaubnis der muss
ganz ehrlich alles andere wäre eine
frechheit wenn das ist die fakten
muschel
wer die muscheln ich respektiert der
seinen arm bald verliert hat schon jesus
christus gesagt
gerade heute da hab ich dann greift
bitte habt ihr geld absolut da kam
kurzen absolut ich hab meine frage noch
nicht mal formulierte schon aufs blut
gesagt da habe ich seine überreste
plündern
jawohl finger weg da muss ich hart
angegriffen da hab ich mich wehren
jawohl der korrekt
welche angerufen das ist ein bäcker ich
werde ohne witz grad angerufen wer ruft
mitteln der auf werbe an ich für euch
ich hab' ich kenne die nummer nicht mal
aber ich darf nicht gegen ihr während
gott wie von ihren leben verlieren leben
halbes herz
wir sind dauernd muschel muschel dürfen
wir uns bitte während bitte bitte bitte
bitte danke schön auch jetzt schon alles
klar
pink radwegen die gestorben weil die
folgen nicht leicht zu beantworten war
kannst du mal an die muschel schule
gehen kannst du bisschen was lernen in
deinem leben was lernen
du willst du bist danke ich werde auch
nicht werden
bitte bitte ich fühle mich wehren tötet
mich entdeckt ich bin der afk darf ich
mich bitte werden bitte bitte bitte
bitte bitte bitte
du bist die beste mutter aller zeiten
wir haben echt wir haben echt ein
problem hatte machen kurz mal einen
anderen shader rein hier das beste wenn
ihr gegner nach faltet man vor seinen
augen einfach kekse mit wehmut von uns
können was geben und praktisch ok
miesmuschel eine stunde ist vergangen
darf ich etwas zu essen geben okay die
miesmuschel gesagt nein brach die
miesmuschel sagt was für eine ratte
alter ich habe gerade getippt die
miesmuschel nein gesagt so jetzt weiß es
nämlich alles klar
miesmuscheln noch ein leben wir müssen
jetzt ernst spielen da hab ich ihn
angreifen
also kann ich selbst entscheiden dann
sagt er sagt du ja oder nein
soll ich jetzt einfach sterben mich
umbringen lassen
junge es da ist da oh gott wie er
respektiert die muschel halt auch gar
nicht was soll man machen was man machen
sollte auf die muschel hören oder sollen
wir unsere träume mit erbrechen ich
hab's gefühl zu wissen ein bisschen
verrückt geworden die weiß gar nicht
mehr was sie sagen will
okay wir können zumindest ein bisschen
auf distanz halten aber ich gefühl
können wir dass unsere letzte chance
darf nicht werden ja ok ich hab' ich
werde mich wehren ich habe mich wehren
wo gott aber wiesen half-life alles klar
wir haben den förster müssen es
versuchen ist okay wenn daum edano mein
gott oh mein gott leute wieder mussten
wir dieses teil bearbeiten aber okay
folge reck und mein gott oh mein gott
auch wenn es geschafft alter schwede
bislang gewonnen sagt dazu also leute
das was mir und dem schildchen bei 3000
leicht gibt es in der nächsten folge
musste kern und ohne wenn ohne 20.000
likes kann ich leider nicht weiter reden
ich habe auch diese krankheit die auch
apa red hat versteht ja bei 160.000
likes glaube ich bei mir sind 20.000
sonst kann man einfach nicht weiter
reden ist es übel leute ist ganz gut
dass wasser zu mir
haut rein macht's gut und bis zur
nächsten folge